it's hard to believe but we're already
three days into this new decade and year
penance aside people want to say 2021 is
when we have to decide a new decade I'm
just gonna call it and say anybody can
call this the new decade and it's time
for another monthly update video I'm
also going to be doing another longer
video about projects for the year
separate from this but it's time for
this update so I always like to begin
with three big things for this month and
here they are big thing number one if
you're in the Milwaukee area that
includes you know the Chicagoland area
of Fox Cities Madison or anywhere here
and you want to get together with people
who are interested in philosophy you
will definitely want to come to our
Milwaukee Sophia that's a society
philosophers in America meeting which
I'll tell you about shortly in the
January section second big thing I've
been a bit inactive because I've been
teaching so many academic classes but
I'm going to be building some more
classes in the study with Sadler online
Academy and teachable so you'll see at
least one of those rolling out by the
end of the month perhaps more if I'm
particularly ambitious or if things go
particularly well and then finally big
thing number three again if you're in
this local area and you have an interest
in speculative fiction stop in for our
beginning of year five of the worlds of
speculative fiction series at the
Brookfield public library coming up on
the ninth we're going to be talking
about Mary Shelley so those are the
three big things but we've got a lot of
other things lined up as well for this
month so what went on in December of
course it's a holiday month so there
were you know various get-togethers with
family and actually some with friends
but not not quite as much as in previous
years we sort of laid low this holiday
season in part because I also had a
grading to take care of you know many of
you may remember I took on seven classes
this semester
well that's seven classes worth of
grading at the end of the term and a lot
of you know engagement with students who
went away my you know getting this
creator can you give me an exception and
all that that sort of stuff so that that
actually consumed a lot of time and
energy but I did get on the radio along
with Dan Hayes he and I did a show for
Riverwest radio as part of their annual
fund drive and we talked about what
philosophy has to tell us about
generosity giving and gratitude with
some reference to stoic philosophy but
also others as well something
particularly apt for the holiday season
had some online events which you know
you can see the videos of below you know
they ask me anything I also did a few
impromptu ones you know basically to you
know talk about the New Year and things
like that and I had for the very first
time in a very long time an event where
we basically canceled it because nobody
showed up I was going to talk about our
Scott Bakker came to the library and
really cold and wintry night and
unfortunately we did we didn't have that
conversation so I'll probably roll that
in for worlds of speculative fiction
2021 because we do have all the stuff
lined up for worlds of speculative
fiction 2020 so let me talk about that
as well I've gotten into this tradition
of deciding about seven or eight of the
authors to come in the worlds of
speculative fiction and so I chose a
bunch and then some of the locals who
come to the meetings pretty regularly
also had some good suggestions and then
we did a suggestion video people made a
lot of suggestions and we did a poll and
we
with our our last three so we've got all
the people lined up all 12 of them for
worlds of speculative fiction 2020
that's a year five of the series another
thing that I did for the first time you
know you notice the Packer shirt here my
wife and I went up to Lambeau Field and
watched the Packers barely beat the
Bears it was quite a close game it was
it was pretty cold but you know very
enjoyable to be there in the stands
watching it seeing how I mean it's one
thing to see it on TV it's another thing
to be up in the stands seeing what's
going on and participating so that was
that was quite a lot of fun and that was
about midway I think through the month
or so what else mentioned the class ISM
grading I continued meeting with clients
well into well even this last week of
December my kids were up here for about
a week and I went down to Indiana to
attend my daughter's concerts and we had
a nice get-together there got to see my
dad and we're going for the family
Christmas coming up here this this next
weekend and I managed to get in a bit
more exercise than I have in in previous
months in part because of the demands of
teaching so much and so now I'm getting
into a regular routine again which which
is quite good it makes me feel quite
quite a lot better videos I managed to
get one Sadler review video done I also
did get a self-directed study on an
early Christian philosophy done and I
shot some and released some some videos
four core concepts on William James and
a Jair that I done for my classes that
were ongoing this this last semester you
can also see the videos of the AMA and
the various philosophy pop ups the
podcast I finally started
editing material again as I found myself
with a little bit of free time so I got
Aristotle's metaphysics book 1 episodes
finished and then started in on my
decart episodes we're going through the
whole of the meditations you may have
seen those on my various social media
and that's pretty much it for the month
of December it was a lot of planning and
you know there was a good bit of
relaxation which which we you know my
wife and I both needed and then you know
some family time and stuff like that and
fortunately bringing all those classes
to a successful conclusion with only a
few in completes so that's December so
what do we have coming up in January
quite a few events as I mentioned we
have the Milwaukee that's MKE Sophia
meeting we're gonna start meeting
monthly beginning on the 7th which is a
Tuesday at 6 p.m. at the Mitchell Street
library they have a very nice meeting
room that we're going to be using and
that meeting will be the the we could
call it the executive committee that
that's the the presidents and treasurer
and secretary and all these people
meeting and talking about what we're
gonna do for the year but it's also an
open house so if anybody wants to come
in
find out what sophia is about get
involved it's the Society of
philosophers in America and devoted to
doing philosophy in public ways so you
don't have to have a deep philosophical
background you just have to have an
interest in it maybe I'll actually
release a video about MKE Sophia this
month as well that might be a good idea
for bringing people in and helping
people to understand what's what's going
on so it's a a national organization and
we're the local chapter so if you've got
a keen interest in talking about
philosophy and you want to meet some
other people who do as well and get to
discuss interesting topics then you
might want to pop in for that like I
said you know a greater milwaukee
community we
people sometimes we come all the way
from Michigan or Iowa to go to our
events so if you're in the Chicagoland
area you might consider coming up or if
you're in the Fox Cities you might
consider coming down you're over in
Madison Dane County you might consider
coming over on the 8th the the next day
at 5:00 p.m. we have an online event or
public half-hour hagel let's just call
it a conversation hour that's that's
what I think I'm going to call them
going forward
so that's videoconferencing with me we
may be using free conference call or we
may be switching to another thing that's
TBD but you'll be able to find it in the
event thing on Facebook on the 9th the
day after that 7:00 p.m. we kick off the
worlds of speculative fiction year 5 at
the Brookfield Public Library with a
discussion of Mary Shelley
so I'm guessing everyone will have read
Frankenstein and we'll probably talk a
lot about Frankenstein and a lot about
her biography as well because she was
quite a quite a person she certainly
lived a lot and you know of course her
mom is somebody who I specialized in in
research on that's Mary Wollstonecraft
right but I'll also be talking about one
of her other novels called the last man
which doesn't get a lot of coverage so
that that will be rather interesting I
imagine and a lot of fun we have a lot
of great regulars who show up and and
contribute quite a bit on the 11th at 12
p.m. we will have our first ask me
anything session of the year that's in
YouTube live you just get in early get
your questions in and I'll try to answer
them we never get to all of them because
they they pile up but we do get too many
of them and sort of open season just
don't you know start with any crazy
profanity or stuff like that because
YouTube will pick you up right away
same day 11 of the 11th at 3:00 p.m. we
have our philosophy chat session for
patreon supporters and that's that's a
nice one on well not one on one but you
know video conferencing thing with me
where we will talk about anything people
are interested in jumping ahead on the
25th at 12:00 p.m. I will have a video
premiere going this will be in the
self-directed study series and this one
will focus on Augustine of Hippo I may
have some others coming up will will see
what I'm able to get done and then
finally another local event here on the
30th at 6 p.m. we'll have our first
monthly meeting of 2012 for the
Milwaukee stoic fellowship that is at
the Shorewood Public Library so on the
north side and if you're interested in
stoicism even if you don't know much
about it go ahead and pop on in we're
very welcoming group again if you if
you're interested in it and your your
little further out Chicago the Fox
Cities Madison Drive on in and we'll you
know meet and greet you it and kick off
the year right so those are all the
events coming up what else is going on
right now I'm in the process of building
my class as my academic classes for 2020
I have two classes at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design one is a
face to face class one is a fully online
class ethics for artists and designers
the class is filled to capacity so
there's clearly a lot of interest in
that and I am in the process of building
up that class site right now I'm also
going as the month proceeds I'm going to
be getting my business ethics class for
Carthage College ready and I also have
MATC class for the second chance Pell
program another ethics class that's for
incarcerated people here in Wisconsin
and that takes a bit more designing and
thinking about how to make it work
because because they can't actually
track with each other so you don't have
that classroom dynamic and they don't
get that much they don't get any like
one-on-one FaceTime with me we have to
communicate through chat so everything
needs to be available for them there in
the class shell that's kind of a
challenge so putting a lot of thought
into that also be building some classes
as I mentioned in the study with Sadler
online Academy if you don't know about
that that's a teachable thing some of my
classes in there are actually free some
of them are you know relatively
inexpensive compared to what you would
you would have to pay at other places
they're all for personal enrichment not
for credit but you can certainly learn a
lot through all of them and as a matter
of fact I'll put a link to the very
popular Epictetus enchiridion class that
I released several years ago down below
I'll just click the see more or read
more whatever it happens to be for the
video description and you'll find a link
to that video work got a lot of video
work coming up got to do some Sadler's
reviews got to get back into shooting
the half hour Haegele thing so we can
resume some momentum with that I'm gonna
have a self directed study video on
Augustine of Hippo and if I have the
time I am in the process of shooting
some videos for my academic students
about topics like you know how to get
how to get something out of reading a
philosophical text or what is ethics
itself or the little sorts of
big-picture students need some
assistance kind of kind of ideas or you
know you also need to do one about
plagiarism how do what plagiarism is how
to avoid it why it's a bad idea so we'll
see how far I get with those but I'll
probably be releasing at least some of
those for the general
like get some core concept videos to do
the ones that I need to churn out right
away are for egoism and altruism so some
some videos on I brand some videos on
mocks Turner some videos on Albert
Schweitzer perhaps some videos on on
Peter Singer or on some other thinkers
who are dealing with these issues I also
need to round out my compliment videos
on the pre-socratics for my my online
intro to philosophy class so I'll be
doing some shooting on Heraclitus
potentially on some of the others I'm a
little leery about philosophers so we
don't have much source material on other
than testimonies but we'll see what
happens
and we'll see if I'm hoping to get to
shoot some other kinds of videos as well
and perhaps some other core concepts but
I don't want to be overly ambitious I
will say this this year I'm going to be
shooting a lot of core concept videos
because I have a lot of material that I
need for my online classes so there
their benefit it turns out to be your
benefit podcast I'm also trying to do
this thing where I take the Sandler you
know the core concept videos and turn
them into sailors lectures episodes
because that is another thing I'm
providing my online students actually my
face-to-face students too so I'm
continuing on with the Rene Descartes
meditations episodes and then I've got
some material on Parmenides and zeno
that I recorded last semester that I
need to do and I think I need to churn
out some stuff on Plato and maybe I'll
get to some of the other ones as well
we'll see how far I can get the other
big things for me as I mentioned I'm
engaging in some some regular exercise
two days in and a match to get to
workouts in tonight we're having our our
third one and so you know I'm a little
sore but feeling better because that I'm
also doing this thing with healthy wage
I'll actually put a link to that below
if anyone wants to get in on the
challenge you bet a certain amount of
money each month that you're going to
lose a certain amount of weight by a
certain date and you know you you're
paying in the money and if you don't
make it you don't get the money and they
keep it but if you do get it then they
pay you so it's sort of a betting on
yourself trying to do daily reading as
well and what else I've got some podcast
recording lined up other people's
podcasts going on there as a matter of
fact in ten minutes from now I will be
recording with the Deaf hangout people
and then finally this is a year in which
I'm going to be doing a lot more writing
projects both online and in terms of
long overdue book projects so all of
that is is coming up so you know a lot
of irons in the fire so to speak I hope
that this is a great year ahead for you
and hope that some of you could make it
to these face-to-face or online events
and that you enjoy the videos and
podcast episodes and blog posts and
other things that we've got coming up so
I'm going to sign off and that's it
you